Speaker 1: The Herschel Walker story is becoming,
dare I say, completely Kafkaesque. So earlier
this week, the story came out of a woman saying
Herschel Walker claims to be against abortion. He
says abortion is murder in his Senate candidacy in
Georgia. But he urged me to get an abortion when
he impregnated me and he paid for the abortion.
And after that story came out, Herschel Walker
denied even knowing who the woman is, saying he
doesn't know, saying he definitely didn't pay for
anybody's abortion. And that that's part of why
the story is made up, because he doesn't even know
the woman. It turns out, based on new reporting
from The Daily Beast, that the woman in question
is someone that is actually already the mother of
another one of her, Herschel Walker's children.
And this just blows the story wide, wide open. It
is an unbelievable new development in the story.
And later, we're going to play Bill O'Reilly's
advice to Herschel Walker. And to some degree,
Bill O'Reilly's advice is making sense, which is
he may just want to come clean on this. She had
an abortion with Herschel Walker reads The Daily
Beast headline. She also had a child with him.
Herschel Walker has claimed he has no idea who the
woman could be. Here is why that is surprising.
And Roger Sullenberger for The Daily Beast writes,
There's a good reason the woman finds that the
defense that Walker doesn't know who she is
highly doubtful. She is the mother of one of
his children. Folks, the story is falling apart.
The article writes When the woman first told The
Daily Beast her story, we agreed not to reveal
certain details about her identity over concerns
for safety and privacy then. Walker categorically
denied the story, said he didn't know who was
making the allegation. Wednesday morning, Fox
host Brian KILMEADE asked Walker. Did you figure
out the woman's identity? Not at all, Walker
replies. And that's what I hope everyone can
see. It's sort of like everyone is anonymous or
everyone is leaking and they want you to confess
to something you have no clue about. Walker
called it a desperate attack and on and on and
on. The anonymous woman said the defense sounded
ridiculous. Sure, I was stunned, she said. But
I guess it also doesn't shock me that maybe there
are just so many of us he truly doesn't remember.
But then again, if he really forgot about it,
that says something to the woman, told The
Daily Beast. Her chief concern with revealing her
name was because she is the mother of Walker's,
one of Walker's own children, and she wanted to
protect her family's privacy. Walker has publicly
acknowledged the child as his own, and the woman
proved she is the child's mother and provided
evidence of a long term relationship with Walker.
It's one of the mothers of one of his children.
Remember that Walker went on the HANNITY program
and answered about whether he knows the woman in
this way. Start with The Daily Beast, Herschel.
Speaker 3: I mean, serious accusations that
in 2009 that you paid for an abortion.
First question, do you know the woman.
Speaker 1: That is making this allegation?
Speaker 2:
I have no. No idea. But it is a flat out lie.
Speaker 1: Yeah, he has no idea. A new
interview with Hugh Hewitt where again,
he says he doesn't know who the woman is.
Speaker 2: So just to put a bow on it. Do you
have any idea who this alleged former lover of
yours is who says you paid for an abortion
and fathered a child? Any idea whatsoever?
Speaker 3: I have no idea at all. And that's the
problem is, you know, when they said I had kids
that I was hiding. A lot of people don't know
that this same reporter found out that this was
not true. Never wrote a retraction. Never
said anything. This is really going well.
Speaker 1: And that is, of course, untrue. Roger
Sullenberger didn't write a retraction because the
story is accurate that he originally wrote about
Walker's kid and Walker actually acknowledged
that as well. Unbelievable implosion. It is
not only a woman who was impregnated, but
then had an abortion at Walker's request. She also
birthed one of Walker's kids. And 24 more hours is
probably all that this story has, given that the
pressure is really mounting on Herschel Walker.